that is the question of whether or not
the cardinals if they take kylo murray
with the first overall pick in the draft
should keep quarterback josh rosen it is
occurring to me that maybe there is
wisdom in the cardinals keeping both
quarterbacks we brought that into a
discussion of whether or not it makes
sense for teams to have two starting
quarterbacks or two starting caliber
quarterbacks you're a big believer in
that more traditional approach of a
clear-cut starter a clear-cut backup and
no competition of any kind no sense of
competition no controversy nothing
between number one and number two yeah
well i you know i do i think it sets up
a problem within a football team i mean
you know 99 out of 100 times the the
starting quarterback is the leader of
the offense that the very least and a
lot of times certainly in the
conversation for the number one leader
on a team or the number one or number
two leader of a football team and when
you
you know again you know you want to have
a good backup quarterback and we saw
that with the philadelphia eagles i
understand that but that's a different
scenario than what we have right now and
this this would be two top ten picks who
are
on the same roster and are both kind of
alpha leader type guys in their own
right and i just think yes it's setting
up for a disaster that way to where you
can divide the locker room you can
divide the fan base and just cause more
issues than what it's worth
at the end of the day by having two guys
that are starting quarterbacks both on
the same roster they're trying to duel
it out and and win over guys in the
locker room on a daily basis
but you know you've said as it relates
to antonio brown that you would prefer
the steelers play hardball with him and
say look this is the way it works we
have a contract we have you under
contract for three more years you play
for us you play for no one if you're the
cardinals you go to josh rose and say
here's how it's going to be
you have received more than 11 million
dollars for one year you've got 6.2
million coming to you fully guaranteed
we expect you to show up and do whatever
job is asked of you and if you're not
the starting quarterback then you're not
the starting quarterback you're the
backup quarterback and we expect you to
behave accordingly and we expect you to
do everything that you are asked to do
within the confines of what the cba
requires and
applicable team rules and i don't know
what's wrong with that if
kyle murray is clearly the best guy
maybe josh rosen ends up being better
maybe he's the better guy and and kyle
murray just doesn't develop and i think
keeping rosen is a hedge against murray
being a bust then you get the best of
both worlds chris because i've been
saying it's better to roll the dice on
murray and have him not work out than
not take him
and have him become a superstar
somewhere else so in that same vein if
you're willing to take the risk that
he's going to be a bust you keep rosing
around is that insurance against it
happening so he can be your quarterback
if murray just isn't the guy yeah that i
mean
that's logical in a lot of ways
yes i mean you're you're right okay in
that way but when you're the number one
pick in the draft you know you got to go
all in on making number one work and you
know i think there you're just asking
you're not going all in there and you're
not gonna give the guy who is the number
one pick necessarily uh the confidence
that you know he's definitely the guy
you're gonna send mixed signals i think
to the rest of your football team too to
go oh we picked him number one but we
got this guy just in case because we're
not sure whatever it may be i think
those are you know uh viable you know
issues there with that conversation you
know and again with josh rosen i just
don't think there's two scenarios and
you laid out a few of them on the show
and i think one you hit on right if they
keep josh rosen okay on the roster and
somebody loses a quarterback in training
camp or preseason his dr his trade value
will
probably be at its its highest point
right there if they do that so maybe
that's the thinking of that but if they
keep josh rosen and he never gets the no
injuries happen and he never gets to get
on the field this year or do anything
and kylo murray is the starting
quarterback man his trade value will be
very low next offseason you know right
now is the safest play to do it you
might not get everything you want if you
trade or the cardinals might not get
everything they want if they trade for
josh rosen because everybody in the nfl
believes they're taking kylo murray for
one so that lessens the trade value but
regardless i just think you're playing
with fire i mean you know you know
there's there's just too many instances
of two quarterbacks where it doesn't
work out it's just not the right way i
saw my father go through it it was a
stress on the new york giants in the 91
92 team seasons
we saw rg3 and kirk cousins you know a
few years back that led to some issues
with the team and the coaching staff and
things like that so
i just think you're playing with fire
when you have two guys like that who are
think they're franchise quarterbacks
we're drafted as franchise quarterbacks
and they're on the same roster
yeah but you know i still think there's
a way to work your way through this i
mean we talk all the time about
toughness of quarterbacks and if they
can't handle situations like that how
can you expect them to handle adversity
on the field and i think there's an
opportunity to go
to josh rosen and say look josh we still
really like you and we think that maybe
something could happen here where you
are part of this team and even if you're
not you're a young guy quarterbacks are
playing deep into their 30s you're going
to have a long career look at what jimmy
garoppolo
had to do in new england he was on the
bench and he eventually got a chance to
play and he played well enough that the
49ers wanted to trade for him and he's
making huge money there and that's not
all that long down the road so for now
we're exercising our prerogative to keep
you here we want you here
and uh we we want to try to make this
work and we want you to grow and learn
in this offense and you'll be better off
for that experience when you are a
starting quarterback somewhere else and
then they can they can trade him after
they have that conversation but at least
to hold it together
so if they aren't get i just look at it
this way and i don't know what what the
you've said that he's worth a first
round pick so
what would be yours your floor if you're
the cardinals
what is the minimum you take in order to
avoid this situation that you think
would be such a potential problem of
having both guys on the team yeah i mean
again i would not try to trade away
anything like in the top 15 of the draft
like i look at the washington redskins
and go okay if they really thought like
this is the guy okay right now i'm
asking you from the cardinals
perspective what is what is the least
you would take to do the trade maybe
short of saying we'll just keep it maybe
a second rounder with some added picks
added into it right something along
those lines whether it's a two and a
four or two and a three or a two and a
two i guess something along those lines
i'd have to think about it a little bit
more and just hash it out to give you
the exact but i think that's just off
the top of my head would kind of be the
floor for that kind of trade right off
the bat hey this is the other thing too
and let's move on after this because i
have nothing else to say maybe you will
but this is one other thing i i would
worry about josh rosen we know he's a
little outspoken right you have him on
the roster he's not afraid to speak his
mind we know that and i really like that
about him but you know that's what this
is the kind of scenario could be a
detriment josh rosen let's say he's
outperforming kyler murray but kylo
murray is the number one pick in
training camp and they're going to give
him you know nine lives to fail and do
things like that josh rosen now starts
to feel like well what the hell is going
on here why aren't i starting preseason
game number three for the last four
weeks in training camp i've dominated
this guy now he starts mouthing off
about he's being disrespected in the
locker room or start telling guys i mean
look this is like the 10th day in a row
i've outperformed in my practice they're
not giving me a fair shake that's how
issues start in the locker room and
that's what i would be worried about
yeah but but again if if they don't get
what you think they should get you're
saying they should keep him right i mean
if there's a floor that you don't reach
with an offer for for josh rosen then
the cardinals need to keep him and maybe
wait for the offers to improve by
circumstance or whatever over the next
year or so
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports